now hi kitty
I've never met a kitten before probably
because my family wasn't a pet family
growing up I have never met a kitten
before I know of cats but I've never met
a kitten I am very much a dog person and
most of the people in my life have
puppies not kidding I think my heart
would be broken if the kitten wasn't
interested in being all I'm looking for
some but some really good kid in action
oh god it's so tiny it's a little hi
kitten how cute are you do we know its
name his name current her name
I don't know Katie I think I might be
bad at holding kidneys is there a way
that you're supposed to pet them like oh
I'm sorry you're supposed to do that
yeah kittens are way more Wiggly than I
thought they do not like to be held I'm
gonna hold it so it doesn't run away its
paws are so small the little pads on the
beat do they pee on you
well you bite me if I touch him am i
holding him right it's like a beat this
is like the same way I feel about human
babies I don't know how to hold them
it's so much better than a cat because
the cap will run away sometimes because
they're jerks but kids they can't do
anything look I can yeah I can't no my
head they're so cute dude like I would
hold kittens all day hey Duncan come
here this is my nightmare
this graphic love me back
oh it's fine it loves me I like it I
like in I think cats are just a little
bit more cranky and I thought kittens
would be like really cute and amazing
and he's so cute and adorable but like I
don't know how to play with it still it
was better than expected wiggler as long
as it doesn't grow up to be a cap I like
kittens because I want to take back
everything I just said I know I said
that I don't like it as much but now
this is great I don't have anything
negative to say about kittens